ja ich glaube wir müssen wieder mehr
über Frieden reden Frieden Gerät uns im
Moment völlig aus dem Blickwinkel wenn
wir einfach heute mal die Nachrichten
des Tages sehen ähm wir haben auf der
einen Seite silensky der sagt schon die
ersten russischen Rekruten gehören zu
den ersten Todesopfern das ist keine
gute Nachricht das ist eine furchtbare
Nachricht und wir wir veröffentlichen
sie wir vervielfältigen sie und sagen im
Prinzip hurra ähm und da geht uns ein
wenig der Blickwinkel verloren die
zweite Nachricht des Tages wir sprachen
schon eben drüber ist dieser dieser
gaspreisdeckel der geschätzt irgendwie
200 Milliarden Euro kostet und diese 200
Milliarden Euro sind weg das heißt wir
haben einen Wohlstandsverlust in dieser
Höhe und wenn man auf der einen Seite
jetzt sieht diesen menschlichen Verlust
auf der anderen Seite sieht man ein
Wirtschaftskrieg den wir nicht gewinnen
werden die noch Russland nicht gewinnen
wird aber der nur Verlierer hinterlässt
dann ist diese Perspektive wie können
wir im Frieden erreichen viel wichtiger
als eines anderen sie ist uns aus der
aus der Perspektive
und um einen ein Ziel dazu formulieren
was vielleicht auch nicht so ganz im
Mainstream ist natürlich wird es eine
Perspektive sein wo Russland eine Rolle
spielt natürlich wird es eine
Perspektive sein wo wir eine friedliche
Koexistenz mit Russland anstreben müssen
und natürlich muss es am Ende eine
Perspektive sein wo wir möglicherweise
auch in Russland brauchen was kein
geschwächtes Russland ist was in sich
Unfrieden hat was in einer Tour sich neu
aufstellt sondern ein stabiles Russland
und diese diese dieser Argumentation die
kommt mir im Moment viel zu kurz Herr
Stock sie waren ja lange beim
Handelsplatz und jetzt beim
wirtschaftskurier die die Frage die ich
mir stelle ist oder Precht und Wälzer
stellen die ja gerade in ihrem Buch die
er mir ein Buch über die vierte Gewalt
geschrieben aber die selbstangleichung
der Medien und gehen da auch mit der
Ukraine Berichterstattung ins Gericht
muss man sagen
haben wir die Medien auch einen Fehler
gemacht dass es zu wenig Diplomatie gibt
wie haben sie den medialen Diskurs über
das Thema Ukraine seit Kriegsbeginn
wahrgenommen
der ist gelinde gesagt einseitig ich
denke das Journalisten wir gehören alle
dazu wir beide sicherlich das
Journalisten die Pflicht haben
beide Seiten zu sehen sie haben
eigentlich auch das Gebot sich zwischen
die Stühle zu setzen und sich nicht auf
einen Stuhl zu setzen und ich glaube
dass diese dieser mediale Diskurs der
ist sehr einseitig im Augenblick ich
bedauere das ich kann es aber auch nicht
ändern wir können das auch nicht ändern
und natürlich schlägt auch irgendwo das
Herz das ist ganz natürlich aber am Ende
sind wir hier
von einer Seite sehr stark mit
Informationen gefüttert und kennen die
andere Seite nicht genau und bemühen uns
zu wenig darum in diesem in diesem
Dschungel wirklich mal nach der nach der
Wirklichkeit zu forschen würden sie auch
bei Precht und Wälzer mitgehen dass
dadurch auch die Regierung immer mehr
zum Handeln getrieben wurde weil der
Journalist muss ganz klar diese Richtung
vorgegeben hat
ich hoffe eigentlich dass Herbst jetzt
hier dass wir Politiker haben dass wir
regierende haben die sich nicht zu sehr
von der veröffentlichen Meinung treiben
lassen sondern mehr dafür treiben lassen
was wofür sie stehen wofür sie gewählt
worden sind und wofür sie hoffentlich
auch eine Haltung haben
einseitige Berichterstattung kritisch
mit der eigenen Zunft ist vielleicht
auch die Politik zu einseitig wurde zu
wenig Diplomatie gewagt also der These
würde ich ganz klar widersprechen denn
wenn wir uns erinnern in den Wochen vor
dem einmarschen die Ukraine gab es sich
Gespräche von allen großen
Staatspräsidenten der westlichen Welt
und
ja aber die französische Präsident wir
haben telefoniert und Pudding hat allen
gesagt ich marschiere nicht ein das ist
eine Übung ich sammle nur das Militär an
der Grenze aber ich möchte ja nicht ein
das war ja glaube ich auch unsere
Hoffnung am Ende des Tages dass sie
diese Drohgebärde aufbaut vielleicht
auch um irgendwie eine Grimm dann
irgendwie Zugeständnisse erreichen aber
das ist dieses einmarschieren nicht
macht und dann hat er es halt gemacht
und ich glaube ich spätestens in dem
Moment wusste man man kann sich nicht
mehr verlassen
aber sorry wenn jemand ein Land
überfällt brutales unterjochen will dem
Land abstreitet als Nationen existieren
ich meine das ist ja in Unding das wäre
wie wenn wir sagen würden die Schweiz
die gibt's gar nicht als Nation so wie
man schon jetzt ein weil wir haben die
Stärke wir überfallen jetzt einfach ich
meine das ist Imperial 19 bis 18
jahrhunderter wir sind uns ja eigentlich
in dieser Analyse und wir sind uns auch
einig darin dass das ein ein durch
nichts zu gerechtfertigender
Angriffskrieg gewesen ist oder immer
noch ist aber wie gehen wir denn jetzt
weiter mir geht's ja darum jetzt eine
Perspektive für eine Lösung zu finden
die am Ende auf eine ja auf einen
Frieden auf eine friedliche Koexistenz
hinwirkt und da sehe ich im Moment diese
Perspektive nicht sondern im Gegenteil
es baut ein Schritt auf den anderen auf
jetzt ist das sind die Gasleitung
weggeschlagen wahrscheinlich durch
Sabotage wahrscheinlich durch Russland
keine Weise so genau aber mit jedem
Schritt kommen wir einer ja einem
Dritten Weltkrieg näher anstatt dass wir
mal Inhalten und sagen verdammt was
können wir denn tun um von diesem wie
auf ihnen vorgezeichneten Weg
herunterzukommen darum geht es mir was
ist der nächste Schritt der uns mal weg
von diesem Szenario dritter Weltkrieg
bringt also ich glaube dass die
Gesprächskanäle am Hintergrund nach wie
vor offen sind ja nicht so das gar nicht
miteinander gesprochen wird nur ich
glaube jetzt im Moment muss Putin lernen
der Preis ist einfach zu hoch das ist
natürlich ein sein Denken ein ganz
schwieriger Prozess weil er nicht wie
wir sag mal rationaler darüber nachdenkt
auch nicht durch den demokratisches
Parlament kontrolliert wird auch jetzt
keine Fraktion hat die ihm dann druck
macht man sieht ja wie auch eine
SPD-Fraktion miteinander kämpft was man
jetzt macht ich glaube wir müssen ihn
stoppen und er muss merken er hat mehr
zu verlieren als zu gewinnen ich glaube
dann würdet sein ganz gute Stichwort ich
habe mich heute gefragt ihr
Parteivorsitzender unser Finanzminister
Christian Lindner der gesagt wir finden
uns in einem energiekrieg als Frau
Wagenknecht das noch gemacht hat vor ein
paar Wochen wurde sie eigentlich
mehrheitlich dafür verprügelt jetzt ist
es in Ordnung Energie kriegt zu sagen
aber wo sind denn unsere Waffen im Krieg
braucht doch eigentlich jede Partei
Waffen wo sind denn die Waffen von uns
wir sind am energiekrieg was sind unsere
sprechen womit wir Pudding stoppen
können na ich glaube die gesamte
westliche Welt hat von dem was sie ein
Potenzial hat wirtschaftliche Macht auch
militärische Macht ist nicht wie aus
Deutschland die Bundeswehr muss erst mal
modernisiert werden wieder aber hat
natürlich was ganz anderes zu werfen als
Russland man hat ja gesehen dass nicht
mal die russische Armee eigentlich so
toll ist wie sich selbst darstellt dass
da einfachste Sachen nicht funktionieren
verrostete Gewehre Panzer die nicht mehr
fahren und das selbst die Mobilisierung
eigentlich zum Teil zum saß in Russland
würden ich habe ein bisschen die
Hoffnung bei allem natürlich was auch
Russland schwierig ist ist ein riesen
Land und leben auch nicht alle Leute in
Moskau oder Sankt Petersburg aber das
irgendwann die Leute sagen das machen
jetzt nicht mehr mit jetzt trifft unsere
Familie wir sind nicht bereit uns zu
opfern für diesen wahnsinnigen im Kreml
um uns quasi eine Ukraine dann den Sack
zurück bleiben wir noch einmal bei den
Waffen ganz ganz kurz also zum Beispiel
Gabor Steinar der Wirtschaft Journalist
hat ja bei Frau Maischberger gesagt wir
schießen nicht Putin ins Knie sondern
der eigenen Bevölkerung wenn man sich
das anschaut muss man sagen und das
können wir auch einen Stock noch mal
kurz fragen aber dass die
Wirtschaftssanktionen ja bislang nicht
so sind dass wir nicht leiden und russ
ist eine total leidet das sind wir
glaube ich einer Meinung völlig eine
Meinung aber ich glaube es gibt keine
sanktionsfall der nur in eine Richtung
wirkt also Sanktionen würden immer zwei
Richtungen und unsere Hoffnung ist
natürlich dass die Auswirkung auf die
russische Wirtschaft dramatischer ist
wenn die keine Hightech-Produkte mehr
bekommen können Sie gar nichts mehr
machen sie sind auf westliche Hightech
Produkte angewiesen die bekommen sie
auch nicht aus China und deshalb wird
das schon eine Auswirkung haben aber
nicht über Nacht das gehört zur Wahrheit
dazu und natürlich vor Ort sagt für uns
auch riesenschmerzen es ist ein
Wirtschaftskrieg und die sagt jetzt eben
Wirtschaftskrieg kann keiner gewinnen
wir haben einen Wohlstandsverlust das
ist im Moment das was wir in die
Waagschale schmeißen die Russen haben es
ganz genauso und am Ende stehen zwei
Verlierer da und was haben wir denn
bitteschön davon deswegen es muss
Schluss sein damit und wie kann denn
eigentlich Schluss sein damit ich glaube
wir sind nicht mehr als als Europäer als
der Westen eine eine Partei die der
Vermittler sein kann dazu sind wir viel
zu sehr Partei das heißt wir brauchen
andere möglicherweise ist es sogar so
jemand wie der türkische Staatspräsident
aber was wir auch brauchen ist eine
klare Definition wie weit wir denn
eigentlich gehen wollen was ist denn
eigentlich das Kriegsziel am Ende ist es
das Kriegsziel eine Wiederherstellung
der Ukraine wie vor dem 24 februar ist
es das Kriegsziel eine Wiederherstellung
der Ukraine wie vor dem Einmarsch der
Russen auf die Krim vor 2014 und das ist
alles mir viel zu unklar und beinhaltet
eben dahin dass dieser dieser Krieg
immer weiter ausruft wir haben ja schon
Fantasien dass wir ein Putin irgendwie
stürzen muss das ist finde ich das ist
Sache der Russen sie haben ihn gewählt
dann müssen sie ja versuchen wie sie
wieder loswerden das ist nicht unser
Ding und diese diese Definition das ist
unser Ziel bis dahin kämpfen wir bis
dahin unterstützen wir die Ukraine mit
Waffen so gut es geht aber dann ist auch
wirklich vorbei dann müssen wir zu einer
Waffenruhe kommen das Gerät uns aus der
Blick aus dem
blickwinkelexperte ich möchte sie auch
nicht zum Mutmaßung bringen aber sie
haben ja definitiv auch eine Meinung als
ich habe vor allen Dingen eine Frage und
ich würde Stock stellen möchten das ist
ja die ganze Zeit überlege ich mir das
schon bin ich jetzt für Sanktionen oder
dagegen und ich habe seit zwei Monaten
keine eindeutige Antwort darauf ich
finde für beides wunderbare Argumente
ist es aber nicht so wenn man sagt man
möchte jetzt Frieden haben ich glaube
das will jeder für mich die russische
Seite nicht vielleicht der Putin nicht
aber ich glaube alle anderen schon wenn
man das sagt ist es da nicht notwendig
dass ein Putin aber auch
verhandlungsbereit ist also wissen wir
denn was er will kann man sich
vorstellen dass ein Herr Putin an einem
Tisch zusammensitzt und sagt okay ich
will was weiß ich die Ostgebiete in der
Ukraine haben das ist das Mindeste was
ich haben muss und vielleicht diese oder
jene Geschichte und dann höre ich auch
und dann höre ich auf ist ist er so wir
bekommen ja zumindest immer das Bild
dass er eben genau so nicht gestrickt
ist sondern dass man mit ihm gar nicht
verhandeln kann wäre das nicht eine
Voraussetzung dass man sagt ja wir sehen
eine Chance das mit dem verhandeln kann
ich glaube wir kennen beide nicht das
braucht man nicht zu spekulieren und das
was wir sehen ist dass er Unsicherheit
verbreitet und dazu gehört eben auch
alle anderen im Unklaren zu lassen das
scheint mir eine Strategie so wie geht
man damit um
wenn die die Antwort darauf ist auch
selber Unsicherheit zu verbreiten dann
kommen wir nicht weiter aber wenn aber
die Antwort ist wir wollen eine
souveräne Ukraine in den Grenzen vom 14
vom 24
februar dieses Jahr ich denke das ist so
oder ist das ein ganz klarer eine ganz
klare Botschaft und wenn wir sagen dafür
setzen wir alles ein was wir können von
Waffen bis zur bis zur wirtschaftlichen
Sanktionen dann ist das zumindest mal
eine klare Haltung die man dem
entgegensetzen kann ob das zu einer
Verhandlung führt mag sein das mag vor
allen Dingen dann sein wenn wir wie im
Augenblick noch in einer Position
die Ukraine haben die die eine stärkere
Position dass die eine offensive
Position ist ich glaube dass man eben in
so einer Offensive eher Verhandlungen
anstreben kann als in der Defensive aber
wir können nicht die territoriale
Integrität der Ukraine als deutsche
verhandeln also ich finde das eine ganz
schwierige Situation sie haben ein
riesen Opfer zu bringen gerade als Land
leiden immens und ich glaube es muss die
Ukraine am Ende sagen was sie will und
zu welchem Preis am Ende sie am Ende
auch zu Gesprächen bereit ist weil ich
glaube am Anfang war die
Gesprächsbereitschaft da natürlich jetzt
mit der mit dem einfallen in die
osteokraining den ganzen Verbrechen die
wir erlebt haben mit Folter und so
weiter also dann würde ich auch nicht
mehr bereit sein mit dem Sprechen sehr
gut wo sie sagen wir können nicht über
die territorie entscheiden da stimmt ihn
vermutlich jeder dazu am Tisch aber hat
man nicht langsam das Gefühl dass viele
Politiker das Gefühl haben die Ukraine
ist Bundesland von Deutschland also wenn
ich mir manche Tweets anschaue und
manche Aktionen anschaue dann muss ich
schon sagen man hat schon manchmal das
Gefühl als wären wir jetzt schon ein
Land und müssten gemeinsam kämpfen und
dann wäre auch wieder die Frage offen ob
wir nicht mitreden müssen bei den
Territorien also wenn man sich manche
Twitter Accounts auch anguckt Politikern
kostet unsere Historie würde ich die
Diskussion nicht aufmachen über fremde
Territorien zu diskutieren ich glaube
die Sympathien sind mit der Ukraine
da bin ich natürlich absolut dagegen
meine Frage ist ob die Politik nicht
fast schon zu weit geht sich so sehr mit
der Ukraine zu beschäftigen nein ich
glaube es ist richtig dass wir uns damit
beschäftigen der Konflikt ist ja die
Ukraine leiten am Ende leiden wir auch
ein ganz Europa das aber nicht vergessen
die hohen Preise das macht uns allen
Stück fertig ne das kostet uns Wohlstand
sie haben das zurecht gesagt und zwar
ganz Europa und das geht über Europa
hinaus und es trifft natürlich auch die
Länder und die Menschen die nicht so
viel Geld haben die nicht so viel
Wohlstand haben die müssen jetzt noch
mal quasi auf Wohlstand verzichten das
macht es schwierig gibt es glaube ich
auch diese Anteilnahme wir werden alle
froh wenn diese Krieg morgen vorbei wäre
ich möchte aber noch ein Beispiel
hinzufügen weil das für diese
territorialfrage interessant ist ich
beziehe mich auf den jungen kippurkrieg
das war in den 70er Jahren die Israelis
wurden überfallen von Ägypten von Syrien
sie waren kurz auf dem Rückzug und haben
dann sehr schnell sind in die Offensive
gekommen und sind nach vorne gerückt und
hatten die Möglichkeit sehr weit nach
Ägypten hinein zu marschieren und in dem
Augenblick hat damals der
US-Außenminister gesagt Kissinger was
bis hierher und nicht weiter dann
unterstützen wir euch Israelis als
Verbündete nicht mehr das heißt dort hat
sich eine Großmacht eingemischt und hat
gesagt ja jetzt ist aber Schluss und das
werden wir also wir würden auch nicht
akzeptieren dass die Ukrainer jetzt nach
rostefanten einmarschieren
dafür dass es durchaus möglich ist auch
mit verbündeten Tacheles zu reden ich
würde hier gerne einmal Herrn Arbeit
Fragen auch als Bürger sehr gerne ihre
emotionalen Empfindungen Putin muss man
schon sagen droht ja manchmal auch mit
Atomwaffen haben sie Angst vor einer
Eskalation also gerade im Vorfeld haben
wir darüber gesprochen offensichtlich
ich bin ja kein politikexperte als
bio-wissenschaftler droht diese Gefahr
noch immer eines Weltkriegs eines Atom
und ja das ist schon etwas wenn man das
immer wieder hört auch von Menschen die
sich mehr damit befassen wie von ihnen
und von ihnen
dass natürlich besorgt macht und ich
merke schon es wird man man oder ich
schiebst zur Seite ich blende es aus
also ich bin ja auch selbst Vater und
denke vielen vielen anderen Eltern wird
es ähnlich gehen man denkt natürlich
auch an die eigenen Kinder steht Ihnen
vielleicht doch so etwas wie ein Krieg
bevor ich hoffe es nicht und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass es nicht passieren
wird aber wir sehen ja auch dass die
Dinge sich teilweise sehr ja in eine
auch bedenkliche Richtung entwickeln und
das ist sehr schwer zu sein scheint da
irgendwie einzulenken
und was ich mir von unseren
verantwortungsträgerinnen und Trägern in
Europa definitiv Wünsche ist die
Eskalation also nicht noch mehr Öl ins
Feuer zu gießen auch wenn vieles an
Kritik gegen Russland absolut
gerechtfertigt ist und ich weiß auch mir
ist auch bewusst dass es ein
Angriffskrieg war aber ich sehe auch in
den in der Medienlandschaft oft sowas
wie Schadenfreude oder Häme jetzt gegen
Russland auf Keimen wo ich mir denke
auch wenn ich es nachvollziehen kann
bitte Vorsicht weil wir wollen nicht
provozieren sie dafür ein Beispiel mit
der Häme also wenn zum Beispiel gesagt
wurde russische Soldaten sind weniger
wert oder
vorhin schon genannt also mit den Toten
russischen russischen Soldaten ist
natürlich es ist genauso schlimm wenn
russische Soldaten sterben die ja auch
wieder Instrumente sind Opfer sind Krieg
ist immer schlimm für beide Seiten oder
auch dieses ein so ein Hauch von
Schadenfreude wenn wenn Russland einen
sozusagen einstecken muss was ich auch
nachvollziehen kann aber ich glaube man
muss etwas vorsichtiger sein gerade wenn
man es eben mit einem Machthaber zu tun
hat der nicht berechenbar offensichtlich
ist und ich würde mir von allen
Beteiligten Deeskalation im Sinne eines
möglichst raschen Friedens wünschen und
damit meine ich jetzt unserem unsere
Verantwortungsträger die amerikanische
Seite alle es sind mir zu viele in
globale big players mit ihren Interessen
irgendwie da ein involviert aber das
wichtigste ist dass die Menschen in der
Ukraine Ukraine wieder Frieden haben das
muss das höchste und schnellst möglichst
schnell
anstrebbare
these weil Frieden wünscht sich glaube
ich hier jeder und das ist ein rasches
Ende hat da sind sich glaube ich alle am
Tisch einer Meinung